aujourd'hui nous avons notre visage
parce que nous avons été très gentils
nous avons nous avons négocié nous avons
discuté nous retourne à la case départ
c'est à dire que nous avons appelé au
président marc gène appelé à l'aide pour
pouvoir pérenniser le financement du
sdiss maintenant il nous réaffirmons
monsieur biya comme le négociations
qu'il a choisi donc aujourd'hui font
comme ceux biotalent répondre quelles
sont les intentions de la 7e puisqu'il
le représentant du président pour
l'avenir des pompiers ça veut dire quoi
vous changer votre visage radio vous
avez durcir le mouvement parce que là
l'état major est bloqué là les à majorer
bloquer les réquisitions qui doivent
être faites ne sont pas faites donc il
ya un certain nombre d'occasions fermée
aujourd'hui
nous sommes déterminés à ne plus céder à
chaque fois mon set
on nous prend pour des petits enfants et
on se moque de nous quand la place du
secours en martinique est ce qu on doit
rigoler avec ça et les ca ca qui fait
fait on n'est pas pour ça on veut se
battre on veut des solutions pérennes
pour les 10